[موسيقى]
اسرائيل
موسكو تطلق سهامها
السهام تتساقط نحو الولايات المتحده
والدرع الامريكي لا يحتمل ويوجد ان ينكسر
والامريكانو لا يعلمون من اين ستاتيهم
الضربه القادمه فها هي محكمه الشرقيه
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو تصدر امر اعتقال
بحق الصحفي الامريكي ايفان مراسل صحيفه
بونستريد جورنال الامريكيه في قضيه تجسس
الاتهامات المواجهه لصحفيه وطالبت
بالافراج عنه فورا لترد المتحدثه الرسميه
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخروفا
انما كان يفعله مراسل الصحيفه الامريكيه
لا علاقه له بالصحافه فما الذي كان يفعله
هذا الصحفي اذا هنا يؤكدون ابو وزير
الخارجيه الروسي
لن تتواصل بعد مع موسكو بشان الصحفي
الامريكي المعتقل بتهمه التجسس ضربات
موسكو تتوالى على واشنطن وهذه المره ينتقل
الروس الى القاره الامريكيه بالقرب من
الولايات المتحده حيث قال وزير الخارجيه
ان روسيا ستحصل قريبا على وضع مراقب في
منظومه التكامل لامريكا الوسطى منويا بان
الاتفاقيه بخصوص ذلك جاهزه ليصرح نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
بان دول العالم يمكنها ان تتطور بنجاح دون
صراخ الغرب ودون فرض مسار التنميه عليها
فلتقلها بوضوح جامد ان العالم سيتطور بدون
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وليس هذا ما
اردت قوله يا هذا لتاتي الطامه الكبرى على
الامريكيين بلسان رئيسه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه الذي حذر انه في حال اند حرب بين
الولايات المتحده واي قوه كبرى في العالم
فان هذا النزاع سيستنفذ مخزونات هائله من
الذخيره وقال ان عليه من نظر في حرب
اوكرانيا وهي في الحقيقه حرب اقليميه
محدوده وفق قوله مخزوناتكم تنضب يا ابناء
العم سام فماذا انتم فاعلون حروب الروس مع
الامريكان لا تنسيهم معركتهم الاصليه في
اوكرانيا هنا الطباخ بوتين ومؤسس مجموعه
فاجنر يقول ان معركه مدينه بخموت دمرت
الجيش الاوكراني باستخدام عده استراتيجيات
ومنها ما لا يقارن باستراتيجيه الارض
المحروقه رغم الحاقها ضررا بالغا بقواته
بينما اعلن موقع ريبارا العسكري الروسي ان
مجموعه تواصل عملياتها الهجوميه للسيطره
على الشمال الغربي لباخموت لتاتي جرعه امل
باعلان وزير الدفاع البريطاني خالص انا
دبابات تشالنجر البريطانيه وصلت الى
اوكرانيا لكن
لقوله انه لا يزال هناك طريق طويل قبل
استخدامها في المعارك في اشاره لعمليات
التدريب ليظهر في الطرف الاخر الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الذي شدد على انه
لن يسمح للغرب بجرب بلاده الى حرب ضد
روسيا طالما وجد في السلطه مؤكدا ان بلاده
مستعده للوساطه بينكي وموسكو في اقرب وقت
لكن موسكو لا تنتظر الوساطه وتسير معاركها
كما هو مخطط لا في اوكرانيا ولا شيء متروك
للحظه حيث افاد تقرير بريطانيون ان روسيا
جندت شبكه جواسيس وعملاء السريين في
اوكرانيا قبل الحرب وقد اعتقلت كييف
الالاف منهم لكن يبدو ان البقيه يعملون
بكل راحه يا اصدقاء اما في الغرب فحتى
دوله الحياد في العالم سويسرا قد كسرت
حيادها وانضمت الى الحزمه العاشره من
العقوبات التي فرضها الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد
روسيا على خلفيه حرب اوكرانيا لتعودا
ماريا زخرفه وتتصدر المشهد وترد بقولها في
الناموسكو ستاخذ في الاعتبار الاجراءات
الاضافيه لسويسرا وابتعادها عن مبدا
الحياه في اتصالاتها مع ونحن نعلم ان
سويسرا لا تمتلك جيشا ليحميها فما الذي
تعتمد عليه لتعلن مواجهه الدب الروسي
امريكا تعترف للصين ليست جميع الحروب
كبعضها ورب حرب قد تعيد احد اطرافها عشرات
السنين الى الوراء وهذه الحرب حتما سيكون
احد اطرافها والتنين الصيني لكن ماذا عن
الطرف الاخر لتاتي الاجابه من الجنرال
ديفيد برجر سلاح مشاه البحريه الامريكيه
الذي اكد ان قواته تفتقر الى قدره رئيسيه
يمكن ان تكون حاسمه في ردع صراع مع الصين
او في شن حرب بنجاح اذا اندلعت مثل هذه
الحرب في المحيط الهادئ بحسب نيوزويك بل
هو اعلان سابق للهزيمه الامريكيه لياتي
الدور على القاره الاوروبيه هنا قالت
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل
الى مستقبل العلاقه بين الاتحاد الاوروبي
والصين مرهون بدرجه كبيره بموقف بكين حيال
حرب بوتين في اوكرانيا اي انهم يطلبون
وبطريقه غير مباشره ان تتوسط بكين بايقاف
الحرب الاوكرانيه هل تفعلها بكين سنترك
الاجابه لاصحاب العيون الضيق لتاتي
الاجابه من وزاره الدفاع الصينيه التي
اعلنت ان الجيش الصيني على استعداد للعمل
مع الجيش الروسي لتعزيز الاتصال والتنسيق
الاستراتيجيين ليقول المتحدث باسم وزاره
الدفاع
من البلدين سيتعاونين في تنفيذ مبادرات
امنيه عالميه فعن اي مبادرات يتحدد
الاحداث والتطورات قضت محكمه العدل
الدوليه بان الولايات المتحده جمدت بشكل
غير قانوني جزءا من الاصول الايرانيه التي
لا تنتمي للبنك المركزي الايراني ويتعين
على واشنطن تعويض طهران عن ذلك فكيف سترد
واشنطن توتر غير مسبوق في العلاقات
الامريكيه الاسرائيليه حيث قال وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي
ان اسرائيل دوله مستقله وليست نجمه اخرى
في علم الولايات المتحده وفق قوله سنترك
الاجابه لكم متابعينا هل تعترفون باسرائيل
كدوله مستقله وجهت الجامعه العربيه دعوه
الى المجتمع الدولي بخصوص اتخاذ خطوات جده
وحقيقيه انهاء الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
للاراضي الفلسطينيه
نسمع جعجعه ولا نرى طحينه وبعد رفضها
مشاركه الكيان الاسرائيلي الفيفا يجرد
اندونيسيا من حق استضافه بطوله كاس العالم
للشباب افادت قناه اي بي سي بمقتل تسعه
جنود امريكيين جراء تحطم مروحيتين في
ولايه كنتاكي الامريكيه تساقطت هذه
المقاتلات الامريكيه اثناء التدريب فماذا
لو دخلت امريكا حربا حقيقيه كيف سيكون
حالها روسيا تزيد من ضغطها على الولايات
المتحده والامريكان يتخبطون بردود افعالهم
بينما التنين الصيني لا يرحم اقتربت
امريكا من ترك دفه القياده لتتولى دوله
اخرى قياده العالم
[موسيقى]